right so there's there's the people who
genuinely come up and say hey could I
please have a picture or an autograph or
whatever and then there's a whole
there's a professional autograph set and
they're trying to make a living so they
show up they've got like a stack of 100
or 200 pictures and as long as you sign
they want you to stay there they want
you to sign as many as you possibly can
right because they sell each one and so
I've always had a really good rapport
with those guys and I'm always like you
know I remember when I first started out
I was fascinated by these guys and I go
like if you could get one autograph you
know and I'm signing away if you could
get one autograph what would it be
Elizabeth Taylor it was oh if I could
get an Elizabeth Taylor how much is
Elizabeth Taylor well she never signs so
she's worth you know five thousand
dollars if you can get a picture signed
by her and I'd be you know what am I
worth and they'd be like 20 bucks
so I had this kind of failed calculus
Ben Affleck and I talked about this
because it's all started for us at the
same time and we were like what if we
could saturate the marketplace right
like what if we could drive the price
down to like eight bucks right right and
then we wouldn't be worth it